hello everyone we're back at the 1953 at
SRI international candidates tournament
with some insightful comments by David
Bronstein himself this game is played
between Tigran Petrosian and Paul Karras
it's well quite an amazing game I could
say that it's a clash of titans
but as this tournament is so strong
pretty much every round is a clash of
titans this clash for instance happened
in round 1 and well I'll just to let you
enjoy the game
Petrosyan has the white pieces and he
plays c4 c5 English opening Knight to f3
Knight to f6 and d4 the so-called anti
Benoni the c5 and d4 pawn are facing
each other but it's black to move now so
seek a person d4 Knight captures on d4
and e 6 g 3 by Petrosyan and d5 and here
probably a move to consider would be
something like night to see to maybe
stopping Bishop to b4 check and also not
allowing blacks to capture the c4 pawn
because Queen captures undie 8 but
Petrosyan plays Bishop to g2 petrosyan
realizes that this powerful diagonal is
a lot more important than then issues
like this a 5 and because petrosyan
decided to develop like this this allows
Karras to go for some energetic moves in
the opening but Petrosyan figured all
this out he wants to you know if he
wants to invite the pawns forward so he
can block the position and undermine the
pawn Center later night the c2 now and
the problem with the Knight to f3
if Petrosyan retreats with Knight to f3
is d4 and next is coming efore and you
can't capture the e5 pawn because of
Queen to a5 check winning that bore
knight on e5 so after e5 we have Knight
the c2 and the d4 now
Petrosyan castles Knight to c6 we have
Knight to be to Bishop to g4 Knight to
f3 and here
the track eros or it plays a five
stopping any future be for ideas and the
problem with I would a move like Bishop
captures an f3 to really expand in the
center for example Bishop captures an f3
e for Bishop back to G 2 now h6 not
allowing the dark square Bishop to
develop with Bishop to g5 something like
b3 preparing to develop the bishop the
other way Queen d7 and after Bishop b2
queenside castle is that okay black does
have this strong pawn Center pawn on d4
and pawn on e4 but it's not really going
anywhere
white position is somewhat passive but I
mean making Petrosyan play a passive
position isn't much of an achievement
that guy could play a passive position
for hours and still emerge victorious if
either of these pawns go forward then
both of the Trojans bishops come alive
so Kelly's decided not to go for this
after Knight to f3 he played a5 stopping
b4 and Bishop to g5 by Petrosyan and
here Karis plays a slight inaccuracy the
best move here is definitely Bishop to
e7 and this stops Petra since main idea
but Rosen's main idea is playing efore
now completely blocking this pawn chain
and preparing moves like 91 to d3 to
create some sort of a permanent blockade
and Bishop 37 would definitely stop this
because after Bishop to e7 you can't
play E for Knights simply captures the
pawn but hear a slight inaccuracy by KFC
plays a Bishop to c5 it seems like a
more active square for the Bishop but
petrosyan immediately seizes the day
efore and well capturing an e3 with an
poisson doesn't really achieve anything
for black if d captures and e3 patrols
and exchanges the Queen's and Knight
captures on e3 this is perfectly fine
for white black didn't really achieve
anything here so after this efore move
he doesn't of course capture it on
poisson he plays h6
making petrol making Petrosyan choose
either to retreat with the bishop
although the bishop doesn't really have
a good square to retreat to h4 foster g5
f4 is an impossible III is impossible D
2 and C 1 simply cramps White's pieces
so he captures the knight and a bishop
captures an f6 Queen captures an f6 and
now Knight ct1 and here we have
definitely the critical moment of the
game and the one Bronstein really
appreciates and one thing you have to
keep in mind here this is round 1 of a
tournament so strong like the Zurich
international tournament of 1953 that
you don't want to lose in round 1
especially not against a guy like
Petrosyan even though Petrosyan will not
become world champion for another 10
years
he won his title in 1963 but he was
already known to be well one of the
hardest players to defeat and what move
Knight the e1 petrosyan is announcing
that he would like to play nice to d3
create a permanent blockade and really
harass this ePHI pawn here caris plays
Queen to e6 and now preparing maybe
Bishop to h3 to exchange it the light
square bishop stopping a move like h3 he
really enjoys this pin on the f3 Knight
and also this comes with a threat of
Queen captures on c4 since the pawn on
c4 is undefended but the move that would
be preferred to this by David Brownstein
and he really celebrates this move he
really I'm sure he was a very proud when
he was writing this book and he founded
this move but branchlines idea is d3
because this pretty much ruins all of
petrosian's plans okay you're giving up
a strong central pawn but what do you do
here is white after pushing d4 this
Bishop on c5 comes alive he's hitting
that f2 square the the pin on the f3
Knight is even more powerful because now
moves like Knight to d4 are possible
capturing with the Queen gives black
extreme development with the rook to d8
and if you capture the pawn with the
night
rook to d8 and black is so active that
this is definitely worth one pawn but
Karis probably thought about this as
this move isn't beyond Karis abilities
but like I said it's around one he's
playing against Tigran Petrosian
somewhere deep down Karis knew that
Petrosyan would probably be able to
defend this position because he's such a
great defender you know
so after this night the night Stewie won
Karis played Queen to e6 with his ideas
but he missed petrosian's idea here okay
Knight does come to d3 and this comes
with a temple on the bishop and c5 so
you have to do something about this
Bishop to e7 and this is something
Karras missed h3 by playing Queen to e6
Karis didn't really stop h3 because
capturing on h3 results in Bishop
captures Queen captures and Knight
captures an e5 completely destroying
black center and this is this is super
enjoyable for white white accomplished
many things here so after h3 Karis
played Bishop captures on f3 given up
the bishop pair Queen captures on f3 and
we have Queen captures on c4 grabbing
that c4 pawn so okay he wanna pawn but
as Petrosyan will show this this doesn't
give black allah a lot rock f2 see one
would a temple on the Queen Queen to e6
and now being down upon Petrosyan shows
what a true positional master player he
is he plays Queen to f5 and this is
everything Petrosyan worked for this
game even though Karis is up upon
capturing the Queen would actually be
pretty terrible because if you capture
the Queen he captures on f5 and now the
threat is of course capturing the knight
on c6 and black loses the pawn on e5 if
you stop this with f6 it does seem like
life has a beautiful pawn chain but rook
captures on c6 and white is simply
winning this game because B captures and
characters on c6 checking the king of
course forking the rook and you don't
just win the exchange you win the entire
rook because after King to f7 first you
play Bishop to e5 check and the King can
go to g6 that's the beauty of this f5
pawn the King has to go back King get
and I just grabbed a whole rook so
completely winning for white so after
Queen to a5 capturing the Queen is
definitely not an option one one problem
though the strongest move here seems to
be Queen - Queen to d6 and branch line
says that this doesn't really work
because of f4 and after black plays g 6f
captures on e5 Petrosyan says that this
is really good for white but
unfortunately Petrosyan was writing this
book in the pre engine era so Bronston
didn't find Queen to b8 and now the
White Queen has to go back and black
will recapture the e5 pawn if white
tries to save the spawn with Queen to f4
Bishop to g5 wins the exchange and the
game but we're not gonna hold that
against Bronstein nor is it really
irrelevant to this game carries didn't
find it over the board brownish I didn't
find it in his home analysis so
definitely not a simple move to find so
after Queen to a5 Bishop to d6 by
Terrace and now of course Petrosyan
immediately snatches the Queen Queen
captures only six F captures and e6 and
a3 king 37 connecting rooks getting the
King into the play
it's the endgame of course Bishop to f1
the bishop is no longer doing anything
and g2 terraces petronas idea is to
bring the bishop over to c4 and maybe a
- to assume this strong diagonal
diagonal now a for stopping any b4 ideas
completely nice to e1 making room for
the bishop to get into the game
rook to a 5 now rub the c2 petrosyan is
ready to double up on the C file
rook to c8 countering the threat rook a
to C 1 and a Petros and doubles up
knife to a7 capture capture
and Bishop to c4 and well this this
position is pretty much pretty much
completely drawn it's very hard for
either player to achieve anything but
they decided to fight it on Bishop to e7
Knights to d3
now pressuring that 'if I've won Knight
to d6 now with the attack on the e4 pawn
f3 defending Knight captures on c4 rook
captures on c4 the position is even more
draw now Bishop to d6 King to have to
work to a6 we have King to e2 each
player tries to improve his position we
have g5 King d1 rook to e8 King to eat
to h5 r up the c1 now has to go back to
the King side rook to h8 rook to h1 and
now h4g for completely blocking the
position there is no way to break
through DF file is completely off-limits
for the rook as this F upon is out and I
have three King is defending it black
only has a dark square bishop so there's
nothing either player can do here b5
rook to c1 rook to b8 now King to d1 a
couple of more moves were played rook to
b6
rook to c2 rocked the b8 rook the c1 and
now Karis played rook to e8 this is move
41 time control has been reached
and in this position the game was
adjourned Karis tried to find some
hidden poisons in his home analysis for
the continuation of the game but
unfortunately not and no such moves were
found so after the game was resumed both
players immediately agreed to a draw and
this rook to e8 was the last move in the
game so it's quite an amazing game such
I mean Karis vs Petrosyan that's that's
something everyone would want to see and
I mean if you remember that position
where Karis had the option of playing d3
and go for some real activity
it's I mean he definitely saw the move
he just didn't want to play it against
Petrosyan in round one
it's the candidates tournament you know
you messed something up you sacrifice a
point for nothing against the player
like petrosyan there goes your chance of
qualifying for the World Championship
match so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it this is my third video
from the surrogate 1953 candidates
tournament by David Bronstein like I
said I am going through the book
well pretty slowly as I'm doing other
things as well I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Armand and Diaries
for your contribution to my channel and
of course Tony Moore what guitar as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon